Chef!
Frage: Wie funktioniert denn eigentlich soeine
Wärmepumpe überhaupt?
Jetzt pass auf! In dem Fall ist es ja eine Luft-Luft-Wärmepumpe. Verstehstdu?
Und darum wird die Luft von draußen, die warm ist, reingepumpt. Und da kannst du
mit der warmen Luft im Haus heizen.
Und wenn die Luft kalt ist?
Wenn die Luft kalt ist, dann wird die praktisch so reingepumpt, dass die dann warm ist.
Aber die Luft ist doch kalt! Wie wird die warm?
Das ist sowas wie ein Kühlschrank. Weißt du? Bloß anders herum.
Beim Kühlschrank ist das ja auch so. Wenn du da die Tür aufmachst und dann den Kühlschrank einschaltest, dann ist ja da die Luft erst noch warm. Die muss ja dann praktisch kalt werden.
Bei der Wärmepumpe ist die kalte Luft –weil es eine Wärmepumpe ist – warm.
Hast du es jetzt verstanden?
Ja, wenn man es gut erklärt bekommt.